I guess tonight is a Tony and Emmy
award-winning actor and comedian he's
done it all like bogie and Bacall
everyone loves this guy please welcome
one of my best friends he's a genius mr.
Martin Short sir how are you
Conan I am fine I'm fabulous you let me
I say you look I've never seen more
lighting on one human being you talking
about I have one little little circular
look at that little hold it there it is
that's all I've got is that little ring
light that's all I have no you look
really good you do look look fantastic
because you're what 82 because you've
been doing this a long time
I served our country valiantly in the
Korean War and I think I deserve credit
for that you look very nice you have a
very soft lighting you Barbara Stanwyck
on the Big Valley whenever they would
show by the way I always love when you
play to the kids the kids need in about
Barbara Stanwyck in the big fat really I
here's a question I have people ask me
this all the time and then I think me
what about what about Martin Short
people ask me do you miss an audience
and I think yeah I miss an audience
Marty short must really miss an audience
because you you are a vaudevillian at
heart you need the laughter look long
ago I always worried about what if
something happened and so I have an
applause record and when I wake up I say
how about this morning I hit the button
and I feel good better than vitamins oh
yeah yeah yeah
do you really though do you really miss
cuz I don't you know I strangely don't I
don't think I do I'm obsessed with
making sure that I do everything right
for my children and myself and you know
I thought of my son Oliver and and I had
a baby and Jane yeah you know making
sure that everyone's healthy is smart
and doing things correctly and that kind
of accomplishment is more enticing to me
than your vaudeville need of wait a
second all that stuff you do with your
kids yeah I I'm the opposite
yes I try to practice social distancing
and everything but I need the roar of
the crowd I never got laughs because had
you never done it so why would you need
wouldn't you something need something
that you normally got like this yeah but
you are very good cricket is one of the
best have you ever heard my crow that's
your crow that mad you know I have one a
monkey monkey I just picture someone
walking by a house right now in his
quarantine neighborhood and you're alone
in that house and say a UPS guy walking
by and hearing that and thinking well
he's gone we've lost him no they just
said I'm not gonna that house with wild
monkeys authentic wild monkeys and Creek
exactly are you how do you handle since
we brought it up a package coming to the
door in the in these times some people
are very they don't want to take any
deliveries a guy came out to me he's
about you know a younger guy he had a
mask on and he you know the glass and I
said just leave it on the porch and he
looks at me and goes
my god you're that guy you're the guy
you're Martin Short oh yeah hey I mean
you got old but it's still you right and
he said that no and then I said I said
well um take off your mask for second
ice I said how old are you ease it on
I'm 34 I said I would have thought 40
anyway he's since been murdered don't
worry I don't care
I've been ravaged by time that it
happens look it hasn't happened to me
and nor will it but yes you have been
ravaged ravaged you have the haircare
products that take care of all that this
is a bunch of this is now I'm using clay
I'm using modeling clay I'm gonna
whatever I can to keep this thing going
let's talk about your dear friend and
fellow comedic icon Steve Martin or yes
you know mr. Steve Martin you and he do
this very funny show together hilarious
show that you've been taking around the
world was it when this whole pandemic
hit you guys were in were you in Ireland
we were it was unbelievable we had left
you know it was very interesting because
we kept thinking should we cancel this
can we cancel this is like the week
before I think we flew over on March 6
and we performed the next night in
Glasgow Scotland and the next night we
were in Dublin and after our show I was
back to hotels around 3:00 in the
morning
Dublin time and I'm seeing the president
say everyone must you know get out in 24
hours you know of course Trump forgot to
mention not but you have more time if
you're Americans or if you're in Ireland
or the UK he just left that and so we
frantically got out and and that was it
so I got back to LA on the 13th of March
but it was harrowing we
and also we were it was confusing you
know we question whether we should be
doing shows but the government was
saying this time and doctors were saying
was fine it was a very strange messaging
at that time part of your act that you
do with Steve is you to really you
really go at each other you're good
friends in real life but you tell these
savage jokes about I've seen you guys do
it several times and I weep it's so
funny but it's brutal and I was thinking
they must love that in the UK the Irish
love it and the UK in America sometimes
people say okay that was a little mean I
was mean that was hurtful and I would
think in Ireland they must have just
gone crazy for it I love it steve says
of me you know what I love about
performing with Marty no paparazzi you
look fantastic
and I guess the secret is that you've
looked 70 since you were 30 people come
up to him and say Oh big fan Angela
Lansbury so and what happens the Irish
probably sit there and just they love it
they just nod and go like that's right
you know yeah you know my father's
weren't raised across the Blaine County
Armagh just over the border in the north
my father was very sarcastic and I think
there was even times when I we do jiminy
glick and I think I'm channeling my
father a little bit really Marty I have
a tape of me interviewing my father and
Marley of course is taking singing
lessons and of course has no chance at
Hell of ever developing into any sort of
singing talent but that's not the point
the point that he's interested and you
know you hear me laughing in the
background it was all that's why I was
done cousins
Patrick and Oliver and I sat up you know
my father was born raised in a bar
shorts bar that's still there run by my
aunt Rosaleen and we
that up till about 5:00 in the morning
you know you start off drinking beer and
then you switch to whiskey and we were
talking with families and people would
cry and you know one of those nights and
then around 8:30 when I came down the
first one very blurry eyed and uncle
paddy was my brother and father's
brother was cleaning out the glass and
he just looked at me and said and how
did the character assassination go last
night and it's in the genes we still do
it I mean yeah well in this country for
a hundred and twenty years and all we
want to do is sit around and talk
treason about each other and how much do
I love insulting you you look like mr.
Rogers
if mr. Rogers drank before each show
[Laughter]
said you that whatever cosmetic surgery
you'd had and you clearly had a lot 20%
more and I think you're done I'm wishing
it had all the work that we all know I
need to get done I wish I had it done
just before this quarantine because we
get where the facemask
I was thinking the same thing about
yourself or about me about you
yes be honest with me Marty if I went
and I got crazy stuff done I mean I'm
crazy I feel like you would in front of
everybody would you call me out on her
or would you let it go no you see in
that case I wouldn't say a thing I do
boy someone got a good night's sleep
[Laughter]
cosmetic surgery does not work in a man
can you get this look who's that 37 year
old dude rising who's a 7 year old who's
been in a fire
[Laughter]
that's all so the problem is it's the
same face when you get bad news oh did
you hear so-and-so's mother died it's
the same face that you're stuck with I'm
gonna get tons of work done during this
quarantine tons they're gonna huge
sections of me so you're gonna go to
that which is a full hospital yes yeah I
have a whole wing of the house that's
just just and their surgeon standing by
and they're gonna go to town to bring
the bugger you go to Conan's house it
and and he'll say would you like a beer
would you like an IV drip I mean it's
just natural you have medical
information going on because of your
cosmetic needs yeah I'm sure you
probably love it if I came over to your
house and we hung out together idea
repulses me so much let's talk now do
you think it is correct for you and I to
go for a walk wearing facemasks and
being six feet apart see I think I think
it's probably fine again don't listen to
me I'm a clown but psychologically it's
tricky to be honest you always insisted
on social distancing with me long before
but that was only because of the breath
I mean I I don't think I'm speaking at a
school here because anyone who's been to
Conan has the breath of a cooler you
could turn leopard skin back to rabbit
you're not have you're honest I'll give
you that you're an honest man
I think I'm delightful in a kind of
pushy small dose way yeah yeah I love
your background by the way it looks
lovely I've interviewed tons of people
on zoom' this looks gorgeous really does
look like you're at Versailles that's
very nice well you know I I have made
money and I was left money
good well listen I'm up for a social
distancing appropriate walk whenever you
want to do I'll do that with you at any
time here's the only thing that's good
because the mass will deal with the
breath it's it's the jokes
remember I've heard them so maybe less
of the jokes from me that's a little
media a little okay I mean I love you
Conan and I can't wait I think we should
do that
maybe Sunday I'm learning to paparazzi
I'm here yeah they found me
oh how they hound me I bet they do
Willoughby's is available now on Netflix
I want to get the web on the bees is
this too close back baby
you know the Willoughby's is it's a
fabulously funny and delightful film
with Ricky Gervais Terry Crews fabulous
Terry Crews Maya Rudolph
oh there you go and I'm leaving someone
out that's fantastic Oh Will Forte Oh
but many people yeah it's a great great
Goods very funny and your vase I believe
it was definitely executive producer
yeah Willa Beezus is on Netflix I was
with Ricky Gervais in London just just
before this all went down interviewing
him for my podcast I interviewed jiminy
glick
please welcome the star of the office
Steve Carell oh my god still Jiminy
Glick he'd be a perfect interviewer for
these times because she'd probably never
bring up the co vid 19 he wouldn't know
about it he wouldn't even know not
appear more until that's what he does so
he's sitting there talking to doctor
pouchy and instead of asking him what
you think is the appropriate length of
time that the economy should be shut
down instead of asking him that he'd ask
is Brad Pitt spirit or just a force
[Laughter]
Talia Shire well that made my day thank
you that's one of my favorite thank you
well listen yes sir
lightful fellow as always you are
fantastic and I love doing your show
more than life it's my favorite show to
do on zoom' it actually is the nicest
thing you've ever said to me so you know
I'm sentimental
yeah Marty short you're a great man come
on Bryan you're a saint and I'll see you
Sunday
all right very good